as of now actually I think what we're
doing with it is Barry's the only one
that knows what's different and that
things are different and initially he
doesn't well in flashpoint that he'd no
one else knows that that anything's
happened and then moving forward from
that like flashpoint will have
repercussions on everything about the
rest of this season but that doesn't
necessarily mean we're in class for the
whole season
it's just comes not easy to me for some
reason the Barry aspects of the
character but flash it's written pretty
basic and heroic a lot of the dialogue
it's just kind of like you should have
to stop and like you know kind of
general that heroic things and so it's
kind of exploring that and how to
finesse it on my own and make it kind of
that fun hockey flash that I think
everybody kind of wants to see you know
what I want out of the character so even
when they don't really ride it this year
especially I'm really leaning in such as
kind of like how can I make him have fun
flash because I mean even for me it's
like if I'm really going through
something in my real life and I'm kind
of down in the dumps or whatever at work
you wouldn't know because I love what I
do and I'm like that's when I'm kind of
boisterous and always happy and smiling
I have a good time and in the same sense
I want to explore this year it various
like just utterly depressed I still like
when he's in the suit I want to see him
have a really good time
kind of like escape all of that here's
one of this if our show has any stripes
here's one of the strengths of the show
the fact that your first question is a
flashpoint the fact that you know this
is going to be it looks like at this
point it's gonna be a long-running
television show and I if this show has
strengths I would argue that one of the
strengths of the fact that bang we're
doing flashpoint
you know there's decades of mythology
and we're not afraid to mine it get it
out there and listen all these sallies
forth won't all be successful but the
fact that this is a show that
isn't content to sit on the floors
restaurants close and move forward I
think that's one of the great things
back that that's a testament to your
question is that yeah we're gonna do
flashpoint then you know what we're
gonna do it we're gonna do different
things and that's you know that that's a
way a show can put Peter itself and fall
into the you know the dreaded jumping
the shark mode but what I like about our
show is there's a certain fearlessness
to do that's like we got like I say
decades of mythology and we're gonna
we're gonna get that stuff out there I
think the time between the finale of a
previous season and the premiere of the
new one I think that's the time when the
most rumors tend to circulate and people
start to talk the most so I sort of knew
a little bit about what they were
planning and what they were planning to
pitch so I was sort of expecting the
surprises that they have in store for
the premiere but actually reading it and
actually like actually witnessing the
stuff that that they had planned so it's
just like I'm just let's put it this way
I'm really I'm really lucky to have this
job but I this this part of the the
show's arc is important or Cisco
specifically because that's where this
is where everything is changing you know
I think it's at this point that Cisco
starting to realize maybe I am a hero
and I think it's with the acceptance of
those powers and that responsibility
that Cisco starts to bloom into well
you'll see think he's still a little
stubborn it hot and he on one hand he's
more mature on another hand he's he's a
little less mature like I think he's
very excited about having ours and he
loves his job and that may get the best
of him at times and it may work to his
benefit so yeah it's finding out but
it's it's fun to play him like this yeah
a little coffee ended up being a really
interesting dynamic between iris and
Cisco and so I think it'd be cool to see
more of that and see more of irises
humor yeah I think it's possible but I
don't know I don't know I don't know
anything I will say what I'm allowed to
or not but iris is very much kind of
involved in that dynamic
she knows the clash and helps it works
with him so it's an interesting dynamic
from season one where she was so much in
the dark it'll be cool to see her kind
of you're part of that but my hope and
what I could be most excited about is
the reporter art and also the Barry and
iris thing I think we're finally going
to see them try and have a relationship
and make it work
and hopefully it's a healthy normal
happy thing yeah I think those those two
things because of this new world where
Barry's not familiar with it with
relationships because the timelines
change everyone knows me I'm part of the
world only he is not familiar with and
he's not quite sure why we aren't as
friendly as maybe we should be so they
have a slightly clashing heads approach
to work mostly because my character
seems to be keen to reveal the
information before they're even so I
think for Barry it's like seeing someone
who's as sharp if not sharper than him